άλλους φορείς γιατί υπάρχει και αυτή πια η εξοστρέφεια του υπουργείου δεν τα ξέρουμε όλα
εμείς δεν είμαστε ενειδική για όλα υπάρχουν μη η κυβερνετική οργανισμή υπαν επιστήμια που μας
βοηθούν και εκεί συζητούμε μετα παιδια τι σημαίνει σεβασμός τι σημαίνει στων τετράχρον και στων
πεντάχρονο να αφήσω των άλλω να μιλήσει τα αυτονόητα και μετά να μιλήσω εγώ τι
σημαίνει διαφορετικότητα το οποίον είναι να αντεράστιοζήτημα στην κοινωνία της κύπρου το ζούμε καθημερινά με
τόσα πολλά παραδείγματα αρά όταν το καλιεργήσουμε νωρίς θα έχουμε λιγότερα παραδείγματα και τέτοια φαινόμενα
στο μέλλων παρόλα αυτά υπάρχει το φαινόμενο σήμερα δε θα περιμένουμε σε πέντε χρόνια να
δουμε να αποτελέσματα όπότε λειτουργούμε δυστυχώς και κατασταλτικά χάμερε στασχολία φρουρί στα σχολεία προγράμματα με
εργασίας πρακτικής φύσεις στα σχολία και εργαστήρια όπου συμετεχουν τα παιδιά μας με ειδικούς και
η κυβλέπουμε νάχει αποτέλεσμα αυτό πγια να γίνει το παγκύπριον κυπήρξν οι αντιδράσεις ένα παράδειγμα
είναι δυστυχώς αυτό εκεί κατηγορηθήκαμε ότι είναι μια διαχωριστική δομη δκμίακαμια σχέση εναι παιδία που
δεν είναι στο σύστημα και θέλουμε να τους δώσουμε μια αντελευταία ν ευκαιρία ανουσιαστικά είναι
παιδιά από τα έχουμε χάσει για διαφορους λόγους είτε δεν έχουν πίσω τους οικογένει εντα
έχουν οικογένει να λ έχουν πολλά προσωπικά προβλήματα δεν είναι παιδιά ιδικής εκπαίδευσης πολλά απα
αυτά έχουν πολύ ψηλόν δεικτη νο ημοσίνης χαρακτηριστικά εχαπι είναι επανέξυπνα κάποια απ υτά τα
παιδιά αλλά είναι ενάντια στη φίτησης σε σχολείο και είναι κάτω το δέκα πέντε που
είναι υποχρεωτική φίτηση είτε δουλεύουν ιτε έχου φύγει είτ δεν παραακολουθούν τα προγράμματα που έχουμε
γι αυτό είναι καλά να ξέρει και ο κόσμος ότι δεν αποφασίσαμε ξαφνικά να βγάλουμε
παιδιά από τα σχολία επιδι είναι άτα κτά όχι είναι παιδιά απου έχουν σοβαρά προβλήματα
και τους δίνουμε μια αντελευταία νευκαιρία ν κάμουν τα μαθήματα τους να παρακαθίσουν στις εξετάσεις
τους και να ξαναμπούν στην τάξει τους άρενε μια προσωρινίδομη εκεί